what's up guys holy [ __ ] it looks like
somebody put forward legislation in the
state of arizona to make bitcoin legal
tender what exactly is going on here
well it looks like somebody proposed a
bill again there's no way that this has
already been read in it hasn't become
law yet but there is now legislation
that has been put forward that clearly
articulates at the state level legal
tender they go through the definitions
of what makes legal tender and then it
explicitly calls out bitcoin it
describes bitcoin in detail it's a
decentralized digital payment network
and it talks about its independence from
a central bank this is obviously a huge
deal what we are seeing is politicians
around the world are waking up to the
fact that bitcoin is good for business
it's good for your political campaign
it's good for your constituents it's
good for your private companies and
ultimately it's good for your government
it won't be surprising to see more
countries following el salvador's lead
and if arizona is the first state to
actually make bitcoin legal tender i
think there will be plenty more states
to follow this is a developing story
it's definitely worth paying attention
to but if arizona can get this across
the line and make bitcoin legal tender i
think there's a lot of people who are
going to start saying what's up in
arizona maybe i need to go check that
out bitcoin is a currency it's a store
of value it's a medium of exchange and
it's a unit of account and whether it
happens now or it takes years ultimately
every country every government every
local politician they're all going to
recognize that people want a
decentralized digital currency that
cannot be debased by anyone cannot be
controlled by any organization or
individual bitcoin is inevitable and
what we are watching happen in arizona
right now is pretty damn incredible